hey youtubers is Charlie so if you
haven't seen the just-released
overruled by some fire you can buy it on
Amazon there's even a Kindle edition
so what it is like in engine history of
West rose written by George RR Martin
this video image is going to be a
cursory breakdown with the chapters are
and some other stuff that you can find
the book just a quick reminder I know
you guys like this I'm giving away
copies the book all you have to do to
enter the giveaway is be subscriber and
leave a comment
are trying to give one away for each
bonus video that I do
just because most to you pry haven't had
time to read it yet I'm not going to get
into spoilers are really specific
details from the bottom is going to pick
out a few bits
for people that are really big fans of
the books this will tide you over until
Season 5 get here
I mean it is literally like a thousand
pages long I haven't got my hardback
copy and I'm actually been reading my
Kindle copy
so right off the bat it's written in
third person just like dance the Dragons
like Turner Martin is writing it as the
master recording history
not so much reporting history as recall
in history
are trying to piece through history the
protagonist name is mister jahn don't
eat almonds name specifically mentioned
in the preface
seeking to give mister jahn does living
in present-day like he's alive
right now we we are in the books history
is all age in history
like very Asian history long night
rising tubal area
the first men the dawn age all things
that we always wanted to talk about but
the Canon hadn't really gotten into yet
technically old man stories are can
because the written by George RR Martin
but you get the idea
I really did like the maister boys the
George RR Martin spoke with
when he was writing into the Dragons
purges the first person POV style that
he uses in the main novels
just to give him is like an analog
Samwell the committee with the most
sounds like when he speaking to himself
in his own head
they did release in a guy chapter for
egg on the first that explain his
history in his conquering in the Seven
Kingdoms
so if you read that the new kinda know
how the rest in the book reads at least
the style that reads
so we have one new character to the next
big thing the he revealed about the book
George RR Martin is that he left a lot
about what does that mean
well it be the pride is left out things
that are critical to understanding
what's going on in winter winter in the
future books
so in terms it seems boilers in the book
for future things in the novels
do not worry doctor maron has you
totally covered he's not going to spoil
his audience
that also brings up the issue unreliable
narration from some other characters
mister ya know the person who's the
reading the book acknowledges the
difference between
recorded history an actual history like
during the Don age for instance he talks
a lot about the Giants and the fact that
nobody recorded any of their history for
them like
they don't have their own recorded
history and at the time no one was
recording history
so much to what they know is all
conjecture I just think it's George RR
Martin winking at the audience saying
this might be true it might not be true
number three big battles be became a
Thrones
when I think that martin is really good
at is getting into the realpolitik up
history
your student sitting in a history class
reading a textbook
a little bit in the book reads like that
you learn very specific names
very specific events he does cover
things through duncan et
the Blood Raven a lot of the things that
we found in the other books the
expanding materials
just haven't really been talked about a
lot the event to the book take us up to
where we are on the show right now so it
does deal little bit with Robert's
rebellion
not as per reports though no you do not
find out with Jon Snow's mother is
like Martin is going to spoil that
number 42 got the magic
summit conjecture sum up it's known fact
the book does this bill couple miss
he addresses the issue people thinking
up heaven and hell like the guy on the
devil
it'll be really fun to revisit
everything went season five starts
especially when he releases when the
winner to in no he did not reveal when
it's happening
and number five all about dragons the
book really gets into the rise and fall
dragons
you can almost say it like the rise in
the fall the Targaryen family
although technically the targets were no
big household in the boiler in Freehold
on another nears is the mother the
Dragons used largely brought them back
into the world
so it is interesting to think that the
Peter dragons is tied to the bed at the
Targaryen family
number six the world is getting bigger
so for anyone who is like a big fan of
the book a map that they released a long
time ago
he explains the rise of all the kingdoms
like other big cities
all the big places like the free cities
for instance he explained how they
became the Free Cities
is a whole chapter on the creation raisa
brothers as well as a number
other cities number seven complete
family trees
so he has complete family trees for the
target audience
the Starks in the Lannisters pretty much
the three most popular houses in the
show
if you see there's some really awesome
pictures that really get into it
it's really really complicated the books
really only address a fraction of these
family trees
but i wanna buy some fire just put it on
for your face number eight
the rain at Kings starting with egg on
the copper he has the time line
up every King to sit on the Iron Throne
to Thomond
number nine beautiful illustrations so
here's just a few of them
many many just mind blowing all stations
that are in the book
up
when
like I said this is a really long book
so there's a 10 it's time to read it
the videos that i'm gonna be doing for
will necessarily be super spoiler it but
I will get into more specific things
just based on state the you guys really
want to talk about
well produces just break into little
bits and just start chronologically
work my way through if you have any
specific things that you really like to
talk about how to the book
just let me know we should add it to my
list so in case you haven't seen it
they're making a whole budget changes in
season five
I do a breakdown right here you can
learn all about him in you can click
here to learn
all about the flashback we're gonna be
getting has read to community flashbacks
thank you so much watching sadat have
bypassed the guest tonight